india is facing major power shortages as
the country's coal supplies dwindle
electricity demand has surged since 2019
while the price of coal has also
rocketed to near record highs now
several states are looking at
introducing mass blackouts in order to
save energy reserves meanwhile the
indian government is assisting the
country has enough coal to supply its
power plants coal prices have shut up
after heavy monsoon rains closed mines
and disrupted transport networks
let's get more from our reporter in
mumbai and iran needy just two days ago
delhi's chief minister warns of a power
crisis in the capital now the government
the federal government is saying all is
well is it
uh honestly speaking the government has
come out with a press release which says
that there are four primary reasons
because of which this is happening first
they say this is because of the
unprecedented uh reigns then they are
saying that because the company because
the country is moving back towards
economic activities therefore this very
high demand of coal and electricity then
there are price international prices of
polls which have sold in the last few
months and then they have also accepted
the fact that they were not prepared for
this kind of a demand and therefore they
have not stopped it well
so everything being said and done the
government is saying that this there is
a problem and that is what all the
states across the country are also
telling us
now india is the world's second largest
consumer of coal is it just un seasonal
rainfall which has slowed excavation and
transport of coal or is there other
factors at play here
like any other industry in india right
now the biggest problem is execution and
planning a lot of coal companies have
been facing lot of debt issues and they
have been not been working up to the
mark obviously because of the coveted
pandemic also the activities were halted
and also they are facing some financial
trouble so like every other industry in
india right now poll is also facing its
own troubles with kowitt adding up to
their problems
and needy other than insisting that
there is enough coal what does the
government do to address this issue
honestly uh until now they have come up
with a press release in which they are
very clearly said that they are making
sure that all the states which have
raised the red flag saying that there is
a cold shortage in their state are being
given extra call from the governments
from the federal government's kitty but
except that they have said that there is
nothing to worry about they are saying
that
so basically all this started because
one of the one of the power player tata
powers they have sent a message to all
his consumers saying that we can be
starting
this is where the whole problem started
and the government is saying there is
nothing much to worry and everything is
under control
dw reporter needy rai in mumbai thank
you
and europe is also still struggling with
high energy prices dw financial
correspondent christy platson in
frankfurt christie more industries are
complaining that the pressure is too
much what can you tell us
right chris well what we are seeing is
more and more industry players actually
slowing down production uh you know
trying to save save some costs here and
handling dealing with the high price of
energy and it's becoming uh more and
more uncertain whether some of these
companies will even make it through to
the end of the year in the uk for
example the steel industry as well as a
lot of energy companies
have said that they just can't continue
to to eat these hi the high cost of
energy uh in the uk they have a a price
on a cap on prices for consumers but
they don't have the same
same cap for industry players so that's
really a huge hit for them there was a
meeting between the government and
industry players over the weekend in the
uk there was not a lot of clarity uh
from that and in fact uh some of the it
seemed more like the government's
willing to let some companies even go
under
christy is there any relief in sight
well we saw that opec plus is not really
willing to up their oil production we
did hear from vladimir putin last week
that he's expecting record
gas exports to europe this year but he
did not say when the ramping up could
occur so it seems like we're looking at
a lot of uncertainty still and that
things could get worse before they get
better
christy platson and frankfort thank you